Oh
I mean almost every country's doing it
better than the United States right now
we're leading in nothing in this way if
you go to Germany you'll find the
largest installed solar capacity in the
world even though it's a pretty cloudy
venerian place if you go to Denmark
you'll see a quarter of the power coming
from the wind you'll see almost
everybody hooked up to these combined
heat and power plants that are very
highly efficient you know there's a lot
of places across Northern Europe and
Central Europe that are doing quite
remarkable things if you go to China
you'll see the largest installed
renewable base in the world you'll see
cities of millions of people we're
essentially everyone gets their hot
water from solar thermal panels up on
the roof you'll see the largest wind
farm in the world if you go to Abu Dhabi
where they've been making lots of money
on oil for a long time but realised that
oil isn't there forever you'll see the
largest solar array and the planet
they'd like to make money I in the
future as well
we're so behind for two reasons one were
the most addicted to fossil fuel of any
country and hence it's hard for us to
kind of imagine change it seems too
scary for some reason the Europeans and
others are just bolder in this way or
more rational or something but we're
also behind because this is the
headquarters of the fossil fuel industry
and they've used their enormous power to
keep change from happening Exxon Mobil
made more money each of the last three
years than any company in the history of
money in our political system that buys
them a lot of power to prevent change
from happening and they've done it
effectively
if some ways I've sort of given up
trying to figure out whether I'm an
optimist or a pessimist I just get up in
the morning and do my work and see what
we can scientifically one has to be more
pessimistic these changes are happening
enormously quickly that's what this new
book of mine I'm afraid is the kind of
first to really catalog it's a much
darker seeing even than we thought 20
years ago politically though we haven't
yet accomplished anything the last year
has been good this huge upswing of
support for 350.org really means that
for the first time we have a movement
going to kind of press for the political
change that we need if we can make that
movement large enough and powerful
enough and I think we have some chance
of changing the politics but it's going
to be a close call at best whether we
get the change we need in the time we
need clearly it won't come fast enough
to prevent enormous problem that's
already underway hopefully it'll come
fast enough to prevent sort of ultimate
trouble